okay wait what's going on I got on my
channel oh my god oh my god what is
happening what is happening right now
why isn't this [ __ ] working I'm on
the widest ISM working guys so sorry
sorry for the nonsense oh it is working
look at that
oh I'm so stupid it's working fine I
just can't see it on my freaking
computer look how stupid is that oh my
god
alright well we're gonna start this
nonsense right now get this first win
yeah of course I wouldn't be watching
either I was on Twitch okay alright
all right here we go let's go to the
boob tube
all right so we're gonna try to do this
I got it I got I got an elite controller
I got but why isn't this working
oh here we go finally God okay finally
hello YouTube I'm finally seeing you
Griffin govern Griffin Garmin we're here
okay
blackout time let's do this alright I'm
gonna be aggressive
I got an elite controller so I don't
think that's gonna help me cuz I can't
figure out what buttons or what but
we're gonna try this [ __ ] you know what
I mean
i'ma I've been reading the comments so
I'm what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna stay
on the outskirts of the circle I'm gonna
be aggressive aggressive as [ __ ] and
then we gonna see a you know if we can
get this [ __ ] done okay
so just be involved [ __ ] be
involved because we don't do this okay
that's but let me put the game in the
description call of duty black out
allowance bedding today's the day we did
this save
all right there it is live dashboard
okay
all right there it is that's perfect
okay hello everybody okay let me see
which one is a see I don't know if I
like on the elite controller that a is
up to I got to change it I don't like
where a is already I don't like Ray is
okay
blackout let's go okay Q please stop
talking about my website okay all right
thank you I appreciate you talking about
my website thank you but we're done now
okay thank you it serves a purpose no
here we go deploy here we go y'all
first blackout we know the season of
mockery I have never won a blackout
match even when I play with other people
we don't do this yeah I'm just sick of
hearing about it
keep talking about it like I don't give
a [ __ ] okay how about that I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm trying to play this game are
you trying to like get a job
[ __ ] just you know all right
here we go people
we do this now we're gonna do this
speedo duties you guys like I got my new
arm a little my little you know up and
down arm here oh thank you for the five
dollars pika blessed oh my god please
don't encourage that [ __ ] please I can't
who's psycho beat up I'll see oh my god
I don't want to know the controls how do
you
oh there you go okay this is still the
same but what's a I don't know what else
okay so this is Joel I can't use this
elite controller man this is too
confusing for me right now okay this is
jump what's this
okay oh yes okay that's get down on the
ground okay let's change guns I don't
know what change guns I gotta get a gun
I gotta see what's X oh my god okay I'm
not I'm not used to having Elly control
oh my god the elite control is gonna
[ __ ] me up y'all this is league
controller it's gonna [ __ ] me up okay
here we go
looking lady from watching on the thing
I'm gonna get into the chat I need some
encouragement here we go y'all here we
go yeah
where should I go damn I don't know what
it go everybody's already jumping now um
no but I hosted 30 people still in the
dropship you know what I'm gonna hit the
lighthouse I'm going to the lighthouse
baby bear my baby's gonna make the
lighthouse I don't think I'm gonna make
the light I'm not even gonna make the
[ __ ] lighthouse oh [ __ ] look at this
somebody right there see that person
right there you know what I could
probably make the lighthouse or I'm
gonna make these you know what I'm gonna
make these houses right here here we go
here we go here we go come on
[ __ ] oh I got a jeep so I can
get to the lighthouse [ __ ] it let's go
to the lighthouse
I don't know this is a good idea not but
[ __ ] it
oh you know what let's go here oh look
at this already alright pick that up
uh-huh uh-huh pick it up oh [ __ ] I need
a gun I need a gun y'all oh my god okay
I'm sorry in there okay we got a gun
let's go let's go let's go pick all this
[ __ ] up
come on get all this [ __ ] okay okay okay
that's jump okay I like that let me get
this other gun - oh I open this [ __ ] up
nothing's in here what's in here oh my
god nervous time I just gonna pick up
ammo that's the new thing just pick [ __ ]
up right okay there's anybody over here
okay since I'm over here I'm just gonna
stay on this side it uh oh [ __ ] what is
that a shotgun I don't want a shotgun
okay okay
okay can we just 50 Cal I gotta turn the
volume up on my [ __ ] I need to hear
Oh level two yes okay all right all
right we got time you know what I'm not
gonna get on this bike oh okay what's
what okay that's X okay so that's X okay
okay okay I'll see what X is then what
is this okay that's how you change guns
okay okay all right I got to get used to
that boom X boom okay okay so we should
play around okay I want to do this thing
where I'm being aggressive on the
circles huh
let me see I'm gonna should I go across
I'm [ __ ] right here oh I just go to
that bridge no gosh should I swim across
oh my god
I must swim across whoo
excellent start so far oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is choking
oh [ __ ] I already hear somebody driving
Oh a truck oh [ __ ] they just passed me
all these [ __ ] ransacked this whole
area why would they leave that dad give
me that armored plating oh can we just
backpack oh did you hear that I [ __ ]
hear somebody oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
got off his thing
come on elite controller I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing right now oh
[ __ ] that's scared why can't I get in
this little [ __ ] car oh we got to go
you know I heard somebody but I don't
know where the [ __ ] they are okay whoo
this is a nervous time all right I'm
gonna stay on the outskirts of the
circle
oh my god uh-oh there's somebody right
there look you see that
oh [ __ ] should I go after that
[ __ ] oh my god oh that somebody
was already here oh [ __ ] oh my god dude
somebody was already in this
[ __ ]
wait does that gun better a Spitfire is
it better than I don't know what's good
or not man let's get all this ammo
though huh right okay there's somebody
over there I wonder if I should oh my
god okay all right we are in the circle
let's just I think we should move up I
think I got to be aggressive huh
what do you think oh I hear [ __ ]
helicopter
where's this [ __ ] helicopter
well here it is
oh [ __ ] somebody shoot at me oh [ __ ] oh
my god where they shooting at me from
[ __ ] okay oh my god this is just a
nightmare
I don't even know what the [ __ ] to do
expected relocated to safe so where's
that [ __ ] shot coming from oh I hear
somebody coming
oh my god dude I don't even know what to
do
[ __ ] are we gonna bounce go go go go go
go go go go go whoa
uh-huh you tried to shoot at me [ __ ]
boom go good good yeah bye [ __ ] whoo oh
my god
okay okay
Oh where's this [ __ ] I'm trying
to be aggressive as a [ __ ] now
you see that [ __ ] close this [ __ ] what
is this gun I think this guy's better
I'm just [ __ ] how do you like put on
attachments oh [ __ ] me dude there you go
okay now I get it okay uh oh [ __ ] how do
I get off this [ __ ] but you have to
attach that [ __ ] repair armor oh [ __ ] oh
I'm straight-up learning [ __ ]
I hear a [ __ ] right here me just
[ __ ] em all
oh my god I'm so nervous right now okay
I hear a [ __ ] guy I'll hear you the
[ __ ] circles collapsing oh [ __ ] he's
no [ __ ] shooting at me I'll look at
this [ __ ] right here oh I see a
guy right here and I'm about to come up
on this [ __ ] and kill his ass
oh [ __ ] I got to go this way could've
sworn I just saw a guy goddamn it
okay well that was one down all right
let's leave
[ __ ] man it's like I heard that
[ __ ] - I know that was terrible
okay so let's discuss what we should do
better next time go let me hear you chat
y'all always got some [ __ ] to say
alright I'm going again [ __ ] dad I'm
going again
deploy solo I don't want to hide the
whole game I need to like uh I don't
know I got to figure this out
oh my god okay we're gonna get this
victory this time I wasn't a very good
finish I just I gotta find the right
guns I just don't feel like the guns I
get are good I think I got the lead
controller like the X I don't know if I
like where my a and B are you know what
I mean I don't know but thank you thank
you
Marvin Estrada I appreciate that
don't be bashful with the super chat
y'all I need some help out here in these
streets to get Griffin studios up and
running some more here we go okay so
this is how you open this [ __ ] okay
what's this
alright that's jump I don't know if I
like jump right there what is that one I
like X star I like X being right here oh
let me see okay oh then what is this one
oh nice - get down
I gotta start jumping for the head right
away black out alright here we go y'all
here we go yo here we go yo consider all
contacts hostile I like the one to the
[Music]
[ __ ] I'm going out let's get out of
here everybody's going to the ship oh my
God look at all these [ __ ]
jumping this way okay here we go here we
go here we go oh there's somebody going
right there you see that okay I don't
want to go there you know what [ __ ] it
let's go across the bridge right here
here we go please let there be a gun in
this [ __ ] oh there isn't a gun
y'all there's no [ __ ] gun okay there
we go can I get through this [ __ ]
alright come on come on oh Jesus Christ
okay there you go there you go there you
go let's go up here okay okay
nothing's on there where the [ __ ] the
circle we don't know yet okay backpack
we're not mad at it not mad still don't
have a [ __ ] gun how do they already
have a [ __ ] oh why am i shooting at
them with a [ __ ] you know what
where's the [ __ ] circle oh I'm in the
circle [ __ ]
I got it I don't have a dude I don't
have a good gun at all yet oh here we go
here we go here we go
get off this [ __ ] we gotta get a decent
gun and mmediately oh my god come on
dude
give me a gun up in this [ __ ] oh my god
oh here we go here we go
that's the one this is the one okay
razor why should just pick this [ __ ] up
huh razor wire and all this [ __ ]
smokescreen oh [ __ ] the zombies that
[ __ ] in here oh my god oh my god oh my
god I'm in the zombie zone
geez Christ oh my god
why am I in the [ __ ] zombie zone well
just help me learn how to shoot though
yeah my god these [ __ ] are just
running at me okay [ __ ] take some of
that [ __ ] oh this is good
practice
when I hear somebody what does that me
oh [ __ ]
wait I think I hear somebody dude I need
some [ __ ] I don't want them with this
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it close this [ __ ]
door boom check that out
we're DS motherfuckas a dude oh my god
oh my god this is just that was too much
that was brutal
oh sorry guys I wasn't looking at the
chat that [ __ ] was brutal Oh oh my god
okay yeah I'm live right now
[ __ ]
hi I'm gonna type in to chat right now I
am live as [ __ ] oh my god okay let me
stop focusing on looting I got a loot I
got a get [ __ ]
you know I like the design bees came cuz
I was like you know zombies were helping
me like focus on how to shoot oh my god
first people tell me i dont loot enough
and now they're telling me i loot too
much come on man just Micah's just
spending all his money on me today thank
you
here we go just deploying again y'all
let's do this okay they see me when I'm
running around
I gotta get good positioning loot faster
okay what it what is looting obviously
mean oh my god this chat is just you
[ __ ] don't loot obviously like
what am I supposed to do awful should be
like is there a button where I can make
my character I casually pick up [ __ ] I
don't shoot enough oh my god you guys
you guys are terrible coaches right now
you know the room I'm gonna shoot enough
i dont loot enough i loot too much i
dont loot enough shoot more god don't
shoot just give handjobs that's the
stupid advice
okay those dumb advice don't I don't
want your dumb advice all right let me
see what uh twitch still watch and hate
to it sorry about that
I've been ignoring you guys over here on
this YouTube okay what oh [ __ ] I picked
that up okay oh I'm trying to work on
how to do this [ __ ] elite controller
[ __ ] but you don't take your hands off
the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay really gotta
figure this out I don't know if I like
the elite controller alright y'all
people that are watching here we go it's
my third attempt this is my third it's
it bump bump bump black out infiltrating
gay I'm dropping early [ __ ] that we
gonna be aggressive our aggressive time
okay here we go
Oh she'll go to the lighthouse somebody
else is going to the lighthouse I'm
going to the lighthouse [ __ ] that the
lighthouse always has a bunch of [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] somebody else is going to the light
oh all kinds of [ __ ] are going
to the lighthouse can we peel it off
oh [ __ ] am I the only one going right
here okay here we go
let's do this close this [ __ ] behind me
okay is there a gun [ __ ] there's
no gun I can't stand when there's no gun
there we go oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
I got to see the killcam on that [ __ ]
that was the quickest oh man we gotta
check to kill cam on that [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] had a sniper from across
the way [ __ ] I wouldn't sell wrong
building oh look at me oh Jesus Christ
that was a I I can't just I can't drop
early I'm too I'm not ready to be
dropping early with everybody and
finding a gun i'ma try this time I'm
gonna try that I'm just gonna drop with
a bunch of people [ __ ] find a gun and
start blasting fools yeah that wasn't
very good I don't need you yeah Captain
Obvious
all right here we go
deploy
oh my god can you guys be like can I get
some helpful advice
Jesus Thank You Henry and we believes in
me the rest of you [ __ ] alright here we
go here we go
can y'all spread the word to some that
I'm out here live streaming they're
fools no here we go here we go we go
here we go yo
all right I just retweet it myself I'll
be dropping on me son okay I'm getting
used to that button right there so
that's to jump okay I don't know if I
like to jump being right there
how's the [ __ ] already on a bike
thing in this area all right here we go
[ __ ] it drop it I'm dropping with all
these [ __ ] I'm going to the
boat [ __ ] it I'm going to the boat I'm
going to the boat y'all oh I got a good
drop on the boat I got a good okay come
on come on come on come on come on come
on oh my god I'm not gonna get on the
boat oh my god
oh my god what happened come on get on
there get on there kid on there oh my
god this is not a good start y'all okay
we don't want to be not gonna read like
this the one guy said don't read just
pick [ __ ] up was that a gun guy wasn't a
[ __ ] gun why haven't I found a gun on
this [ __ ] yet okay here we go
let's go come up blastin don't waste
time just pick [ __ ] up right
nissim potential collapse detected
advisory location to indicates it's safe
dad huh oh this is my gun right here
give me this thank you I'll take that
whatever the [ __ ] it is give me this
give me this you look good look at me
I'm just picking [ __ ] up I'm reading we
just pick his [ __ ] up son huh
trauma kit oh you already have one of
those yeah I do all right where to
[ __ ] this thing at is there a boat
over here that I can get onto oh my god
I'm surprised nobody else came to the
boat right wait what kind of gun is this
that I have oh [ __ ] us I'm doing that
thing again where I'm taking too long to
loot
okay I feel it right now guys I kind of
see what you're saying okay I'm over
looting okay here we go I gotta get that
dough okay here we go
don't want a [ __ ] axe wait this gun
better I don't know what I think this
guns better okay here we go
no [ __ ] okay so now I have to like equip
[ __ ] right um I guess not
I don't know what I'm doing wait I got
to go here we go all right how far
away's a circle I'm not that far away
okay okay okay okay we got it go huh
take a quick look see if anybody's
around all right
all right y'all here we go practice my
slide okay that was my lead controller
slide hard to see if any [ __ ]
are on that thing oh [ __ ] okay oh [ __ ]
go slow right here oh there was somebody
over there oh [ __ ]
unless not what I wanted to do
oh my god
I think somebody's in here
I Supply Drop inbound I hear some
shootin
wait did I see somebody oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay here's some shootin there's
some shootin going on right above me I
guess I gotta be aggressive huh I'll
come in the circle let's get down low
weight down low y'all
oh [ __ ] okay here we go
Griffin diamond welcome to Griffin
gaming I don't even know how to climb
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm coming this
time in these trees y'all she went I
mean you think I should go over here to
these houses I don't think anybody's
been over there yet oh there's somebody
go check that guy out take aim
oh [ __ ]
check me out still in a circle - yes
[ __ ]
oh yeah aggressive is a [ __ ] on
this dude [ __ ] oh shoot him in the head
again okay
oh [ __ ] oh my god got that kill whoo
okay should I loop this [ __ ] I
have to huh okay Oh get this
okay get that [ __ ]
extended mag backpack sniper scope okay
okay okay how do you get out of that all
right now how do our clip [ __ ] okay boom
boom here we go all right all right all
right all right whoo all right okay I
gotta calm the [ __ ] down
oh I gotta use these things
okay here we go all right okay this
helicopter god damn it dude yes all
right I'm gonna stay on the rim of the
circle here oh wait where does she wears
this [ __ ] at all I'm close wait wait
wait
oh you know what imma do I'm gonna go
around this way oh oh my god
oh I should have taken a tactical kids
Amba [ __ ] again I don't I don't have
time for zombies I need some ammo oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] how close am i I'm close
where is that guy I hear somebody oh
[ __ ] I gotta go
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh my god this is oh [ __ ]
let's go hit me oh damn it
oh my god oh my god oh my god I was too
slow let's good just kill cam mother
[ __ ] man oh that is so goddamn
annoying oh he sees me right here he's
trying to get me come on jump jump jump
jump and I was number 31 oh my god dude
God is just oh my god
I did get a kill and it was an
aggressive kill I wasn't [ __ ] around
with that kill but number 31 kai tail
man
if I would have got over and been able
to shoot all right one more one more
y'all so frustrating
oh my god what a [ __ ] way to die
yes I'm wearing pants [ __ ] God
you guys are just just I can't stand
just chat can't I can't stand it oh my
god I can't believe I got ran over
oh my god you know what I felt better
about my gameplay on that one what do
y'all think
whatever okay you just don't want me to
have pants on yeah
punk-ass pervert going after this white
guy to me a white boy come here white
boy come here white boy oh slide by
slide give me this give me this and for
the head black out
you're not gonna see any hogs okay I'm
jumping right out [ __ ] that you know
what I'm headed to those uh those things
over there
okay here's a good set of houses right
here here we go right here come on come
on baby oh my god this wasn't a good
landing this was not a good landing huh
here we go here we go yo here we go yo
so what's to us toss us in here are you
should I pick [ __ ] up picks it up picks
it up close the door all right go let's
go let's go let's go please be a gun up
here why the [ __ ] isn't there a gun up
here man goddammit what a waste of house
oh my god it's a gun in here okay I'll
take it I'll take it there's two guns
all right
oh this is my gun right here that's my
killer gun let's see if there's a back
pack up here okay this is all [ __ ]
man am I in the circle [ __ ] I don't know
man I gotta find a backpack of some
other [ __ ] what is this gun should I get
this one
or rampart yeah let's get a rampart okay
I'll come deep into circle deep in the
circle [ __ ]
all right we got to go I gotta find some
other [ __ ] I'm trying to quick Lou got
that quick loot on y'all get y'all quick
loot oh my here's a [ __ ] truck right
here but I don't need that [ __ ] oh here
we go here we go look at that yes okay
no
I hear some shooting oh my god can I
just get a [ __ ] backpack there we go
damn I wonder if I should go across this
bridge I don't know yet I should
probably wait and see what a circle is
huh you know what let's go over here I'm
away from the circle okay where is it
I'm still knee-deep in it so I don't
gotta worry oh my god I hear some [ __ ]
oh here we go this a bunch of [ __ ] over
here what is this
rockets I don't want that [ __ ] what's
that down near no I don't want hope god
I don't want rocket so it doesn't matter
huh maybe I should get that rocket now
well here's a backpack maybe I should
pick up the rocket launcher and shoot
people from a distance way that's super
just circle I'm still in town I'm in the
circle I mean I just kind of feel like I
don't alright let's go over here Oh what
am i doing
[ __ ] I don't know what that is I don't
know if it's better or worse I just I
just don't know man okay oh she does a
bunch of [ __ ] in here
I need f56 I need that five six see if I
need to equip anything no I don't okay
oh there you go
oh now I'm starting to get it okay see I
wouldn't do that before I wasn't
attaching [ __ ] all right you know what
let's get down here okay we in the
circle so I'm in the circle [ __ ] it this
camp a little bit let's see what else is
in here see I should have got those
Rockets could a [ __ ] blew that [ __ ]
out of the sky can we just barricade
[ __ ] all right okay I'm gonna wait in
here and see window circle if the circle
comes Oh
okay guys rampart is better no I have a
rampart
oh I know what I'm gonna do
who Supply Drop inbound
I see let's see
okay I'm still in the circle I'm still
in a circle with 40 people left I wish
you can get up there that'll be kind of
dope all right
oh I hear somebody come in
that's [ __ ] all right just circles
collapsing oh here we go
here we go yo here we go yo oh I'm still
right there I'm still right there I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna wait I don't like
playing like this I think I should be a
tad more aggressive what do you think
okay here's some shooting outside
oh [ __ ]
okay here we go here we go all right all
right all right
Oh should I gotta be careful
where's this helicopter goddamn goddamn
it dude
all that helicopter just landed oh I
think somebody shot at it oh I see a
[ __ ] okay all right I'm gonna be
let me just
oh she here comes somebody
connect coal supply drop incoming
sitrep circle collapse him in and get to
safety oh [ __ ]
oh my god okay
oh I hear something I hear some shots
all right we are in the circle
oh [ __ ] don't you see somebody okay I'm
in the circle okay here we go
here we go
oh my god I wonder why she hit that
building my dear what about all these
buildings right here oh I get to high
ground up there actually hit to those
buildings wait let's see here we go here
we go here we go
alright here we go y'all oh here we go
here we go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I can't get
in this building
oh [ __ ] I'm so far away from the [ __ ] oh
my god whoo okay here I hear him let me
see if I could see him oh this shooting
to the left you know what [ __ ] dis we
got 59 seconds I got to go this way [ __ ]
I here comes somebody I owe some people
went into that room right there
well how far away am i oh I'm so [ __ ]
far I gotta go
[ __ ] it let's go Go Daddy Go Go Daddy go
what is a truck right there yes there's
a guy oh man oh I got shot from
different areas what I was terrible oh
my gosh I don't even think I got shot by
the guy that shot me oh man this is this
is just a nightmare I'm not gonna cry
without glasses [ __ ] I need my
glasses to see god I hate you people I
hate you
hey you guys are just not nice some of
you are just alright one more game
that's it that's about an hour just one
more game amout I'm gonna be on later
again I'll play some some apex maybe
some fortnight but we moving up y'all
look I got my little new mic stand
yeah I'm trying to win a solo I'm trying
to win that solo match later I'll come
on and then whoever jumps in my thing
first I'll play with you
okay
hmm oh this is it it's gonna be the one
y'all just gonna beat or weren't just
gonna be the one baby black out [ __ ]
just how we doing it we just drop in
right away to aggressive style drop drop
drop drop drop drop it like it's hot
drop it like it's hot
I'm going right down to this building
right here I'm not even gonna [ __ ]
around here we go right to this building
look at me ah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
is there somebody here oh my god this
[ __ ] here already get a gun
Griffin well how do I switch to that oh
man I thought I had room is the axe how
do you load the axe [ __ ] okay I go again
that was [ __ ] that was [ __ ] we
going again I just man dude that's been
I was trying to be aggressive I gotta
get used to being aggressive that's the
thing is hard
Griffin govern
it's got I got to change my play style
that's what it is I'm trying to figure
out like what's the proper police style
okay we go deploy all right just the
last one y'all so this is it we gots to
do this wait let me go over to twitch
hit with twitch is saying hey twitch hi
eight people on twitch which is why I
don't stream to this that often I'll
just come to it all the time Marvin you
spending all your money dude like what
are you doing bro now starting to get
yeah come on guys you gotta help Marvin
out he can't be the only one super
chatting okay here we go
I'm getting more comfortable this is it
okay I'm being aggressive that was too
aggressive I just got to get a gun right
away I just can't stand when like you
know when you drop and there's no gun
I'm going 720 I should have went with
1080 know what's going on on this
all right here we go
like I remember to do this [ __ ] pick up
pick up pick up pick up I gotta practice
my shootin
I got to try aiming for the head aim for
the head
aim for the head aim for the head there
you go aim for the head aim for the head
aim for the head I think I'm ready black
out all right here we go I'm still gonna
be aggressive though I'm dropping right
away
should I go boat no I'm not gonna go to
the boat too many men [ __ ] go to the
boat not going to the boat no boat
action drop drop
everybody's going so you know where I'm
going I'm going to this building yeah
I'm going to this [ __ ] right here we're
gonna land on the roof of this [ __ ]
there's always a lot of [ __ ] right here
come on baby come on baby come on baby
come on baby come on baby oh please let
me land on a roof okay
okay give me this nice give me this give
me that give me that
give me a gun uh-huh give me this okay
okay okay uh-huh uh-huh
give me this hat I don't know why I got
a [ __ ] hat they don't make any sense
Oh grappling gun I'll take it oh just
hear somebody else with a gun
a potential collapse detected at five's
relocation to indicate it safe zone oh
[ __ ] I gotta find a [ __ ] okay is that
tight is this a good gun yeah [ __ ] it
oh I like this gun man the noises you
make your individual noises you sounds
like a [ __ ] ton of people it's really
annoying okay wait am I in a circle all
[ __ ] I'm in the circle - [ __ ] it let's
say a construction site you can jump off
this beach - right oh here we go
my inventories fall I need a [ __ ]
backpack [ __ ] I must stay up here though
oh I hear a [ __ ]
oh my god this is so I got to go slow as
[ __ ]
my circle collapse imminent get to
safety
okay I'm still in the circle but I don't
have any [ __ ] I just I need a
backpack
can you jump off the building and your
[ __ ] will your little gliding [ __ ] will
happen anybody know
are you whole jump okay
I know some more people are here oh my
god this is so infuriating
there's a I just need a [ __ ] backpack
I might to get off of this shit's I know
we're still in the circle though oh
there's a [ __ ] helicopter thing but
is there anything I shouldn't jump down
there how die
oh here a bunch of shooting right here
I'll [ __ ] that call Supply Drop incoming
okay okay we're good
oh [ __ ]
you know what check this out
I don't know if I killed him I have one
rocket left
was there another helicopter on unless
the supply ship
No
I don't want a [ __ ] hat I'll people
to shooting over there can you aim at
people I'll be so dope if I could just
blast somebody from up here right damn
it he jumped
oh Sh is there an elevator coming up oh
[ __ ] somebody came up the elevator
where's the elevator oh I think I should
jump off this [ __ ] so I can jump off
wait wait there's somebody where is that
somebody no Doherty have one of those oh
I didn't even have one of those on yet
god damn dude why here's somebody
expected we get mother oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man I mean the killcam
this is ridiculous like this is why I am
terrible at this game
I mean spill [ __ ] just fell off the
roof okay oh my god let's see the
killcam did not even go show to kill cam
cuz that was so stupid oh my god I
didn't even she did not even you don't
they don't even show you the kill cam
when you kill yourself I literally just
fell off a [ __ ] building like that
was [ __ ] stupid all right y'all I
tried
I'm gonna do it again I'm gonna go do
like 60 70 minute videos of this when I
don't do it that's it and I try it again
but that was it thank you for listening
to Gregory I appreciate you I know it
was bad but let's get can we get some
positive feedback you know I I was more
aggressive I got a couple of kills you
know I shot down a helicopter
you know I'm picking up weapons the
right way I was trying to do the batwing
thing I don't know why it didn't work
but anyways you guys are great and I
appreciate you guys watching and have a
good one
thanks for watching listen